[موسيقى]
انا سمير مصطفى ابو دهس من مواليد حيفا
1937 بدات قصتي مع
القديم او الانتيكا او العتيق زي ما بسموه
بالعربي في سنه 1947 كان عمري عشر سنين
وقتها
[موسيقى]
بس انت ال 48 بالنكبه تركنا كل شيء زي كل
الفلسطينيه
وهاجرنا للبنان ضلت انا هذه القطعه
القديمه
والقطعه الاثاث في مخيلتي في هذه الفتره
انا كنت برضه
احب كثير الاشياء هذه لكن ما كانت من
متناول ولا واليد الوالد لكن من شغفي في
الموضوع درست الفن الاسلامي والخزف
واقتنيت قطعه من
فصل الخزف من احد الاصدقاء ايه اليونانيين
اللي كان خزاف جيد ولا تزال القطعه معي
وهاي تعتبر اول قطعه في مجموعته بسنه
السبعه وخمسين
[موسيقى]
المجموعه الاردنيه الفلسطينيه بتبدا من
هون هذه كلها مجموعه للعائله الهاشميه
وخصوصا المرحوم الملك حسين
طيب الله صراع مجموعه كبيره له فيها
الاشياء الصحون هذه اللي هي بالنسبه
للذكرى
الخمسينيه اللي توليه الحكم في المجموعه
الاردنيه الفلسطينيه في مجموعه صور الاردن
وفلسطين في من 1900 الى 1948 للمدن عمان
جرش سلط
فلسطين
ومجموعه برضه لصور
الهاشميين الملك حسين
والعائله الهاشميه هذه من المجموعه
الاردنيه الفلسطينيه اللي هي الادوات
والفخار اللي استعمل في البيوت في قبل
الخمسينات يمكن او يمكن لازال في بعض
البيوت مستعمله نفس الفخار موجود
بفلسطين وال عند انك بخروج الفلسطينيين من
بيوتهم ومنازلهم اكثر شيء كانوا يحملوا
ومفاتيح بيوتهم رائعه املا بالعوده
القريبه للبيوت هذه جزء من المفاتيح
اللي كانوا يستعملوها هدول القطع كلها
معزومها من 1920 1930 خزف الفلسطيني صار
مشهور جدا في العالم كله في كل في كل
المحلات
المتاحف في العالم بفتخروا انه يكون عندهم
قطعه من الخزف الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
علاقتنا مع المجتمع المحلي بزورنا كثير من
المهتمين
للاطلاع على هذه كذلك الباحثين طلاب
المهتمين في الموضوع التراث كما نتبادل مع
تحف في الاردن معلومات حول بعض التعف
المتحف مفتوح لاي شخص بحبه يزور في اي وقت
[موسيقى]
ماذا بعد يعني انا
وصلت الان 86 سنه لذلك انا بودي انه يوم
من الايام نلقى مؤسسه او بنك او جماعه
تقدر تقوم
بهذا العبء اللي احنا
تحملنا لخمسين سنه تقريبا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات